why why isn't the Book of Enoch
considered like Canon canonical because
there is no indication that the prophet
Enoch wrote it it is what we call Sur
pigal meaning it is a writing attributed
to Enoch but Enoch did not write it so
why would we include a book in our Canon
that did not come from the prophet Enoch
or Enoch whether a prophet or not we're
not told explicitly but if a prophet is
someone that God speaks to in a
miraculous way like appears to him in a
vision or appears to him in time and
space in visible form or in a
and he hears God audibly then Enoch was
a prophet in that sense even though he's
not said to be a prophet
explicitly and he wasn't there after the
flood he was taken to be with God or God
took him to the what we call the Nether
world the underworld Before the Flood so
if he wrote a book we don't have any
historical evidence such a book was
written by Enoch because there's no
mention of it in the books written by
the Old Testament proph ETS after the
time of
Noah
okay all right you get my point yeah so
then if there is no indic indication
that Enoch wrote a book because he is
what they call an anti-d livian meaning
he is a pre flood holy servant of God a
holy man of God whom God spoke with and
whom he walked before God in a manner
pleasing to God and God took him out of
the Earth
without having to First physically die
and then transported him to the
underworld well if he did write a book
then that means Noah must have had a
copy of that book because everything was
destroyed by the flood except Noah and
his family and there's only seven family
members and the animals that Noah
brought on the ark so that means Noah
would have had
to taken that book and then pass it on
to his generations to his sons and their
children and they would have to have
copied it but then if there was such a
book that was copied and recopied why is
there no mention of it in the books of
the Old Testament when the books of the
Old Testament do mention other books
such as the books of the war the book of
the wars of Yahweh yahwah and the Book
of jasher and The Chronicles of the
Kings what about like the is the like
the reference in Jude is that not
actually a reference to no that could be
Jude quoting a book that was deemed
authoritative by the people that he's
writing to because don't forget in the
New Testament Paul and the others will
quote writings that Their audience
accept as authoritative not because they
believe it's inspired but because the
people they're writing to accept its
Authority because that's what Paul did
with the Greeks the Athenians in Acts
1728 he quoted two Greek Pagan writers
authors poets aratus and a
menades to prove
his point because the Greeks that he was
talking to accepted these writers as
authoritative Paul also did that in
Titus 1112 where he quoted a false
prophet of the
cretans that doesn't mean he believed
these men were inspired or their
writings are inspired but he quoted them
because the people he's writing to look
to these men as authorities and viewed
their writings as authoritative so Jude
may have done the same thing or it's
also possible that there was a tradition
of Enoch prophesying that had been
preserved orally and eventually was
written as part of the Book of
Enoch okay so so it's possible that part
of it might be like actual like yeah
there is historical truth in The Book of
Enoch why because things could be passed
on
orally and those oral Traditions could
be accurately preserved and then written
down in a
document and then attributed to Enoch
falsely I don't think everything Enoch
is not true I do believe it has a lot of
historical truths historical elements
for example it's Enoch that tells us the
sons of God in Genesis six were
rebellious angels that left heaven and
then had sex with women and
sired hybrids half angels half human and
that these angels also taught man kind
Advanced Sciences
astrology you know zoology botany etc
etc oh okay why wouldn't I believe
that see all right like that would be
like the best explanation or like say it
again like like why do you trust that
explanation though if you don't know if
like it came from because there are
things in Enoch that find support in the
books that we believe to be inspired by
God and historically accurate for
example does Genesis 6 2:4 mention sons
of God having sex with daughters of men
yes it's mentioned okay so does that
then lead me to assume and believe that
there would have been oral Traditions
that were passed on orally from one
generation to the next because in
Genesis 62:4 it's very brief it's brief
sons of God saw the daughters of men
that they were fair and beautiful and
entered into them and had children with
them well
obviously the audience of Genesis would
have known a lot more than what's
written now if Moses wrote Genesis 6 and
I know he did because the evidence shows
he did I'm not a liberal I do believe
Moses was inspired by God to record past
history accurately then that means when
Moses wrote Genesis 62-4
something very brief we would assume and
expect that he would have elaborated on
it he would have explained it in detail
to the Israelites therefore what Moses
wrote briefly he would have expounded in
great detail and that detailed
explanation could have been passed on
Word of Mouth until finally some of
those Traditions were found in
Enoch right okay okay right yeah do you
assume that when Gen when Moses wrote
Genesis 2 to 4 the sons of God saw the
daughters of men that they were fair and
they entered with into them and had
Offspring from them that's all Moses
would have said for 40 years that's it
no don't you think there have been
people like you would ask questions hey
Moses what does this
mean right right and do you think mes
would that was written down only like
the the main point do you think Moses
would have said hey you know what you
only go by what is written don't ask me
sh right yeah like for us now that's the
only thing like we don't need like no
well we do have Traditions that's the
point Enoch contains some of those
Traditions so we don't assume everything
in Enoch is not historical that it's a
complete fabrication no we assume that
it does contain historical truths there
are elements that are historical but we
tread lightly and be
careful okay
okay right right